so there's a quote at the end of your
demo reel and it says as a filmmaker you
have the opportunity to make projects of
quality different films that mean
something that is what I look for when
you are deciding on which project to
work on next do you spend time thinking
of the business side of it or the
creative side of it I think that it
wouldn't be honest to say that a
filmmaker never thinks about the
business side of a film because if you
see your career not only as a
progression but as something that you're
monetizing that you can pay your bills
with you know I I do film exclusively
that's what I do
I couldn't afford to pay my bills if I
didn't think about what the business
capacity is for a film that I'm making
as so that's certainly a part of it
but I think at the end of the day if
it's not something that speaks to you
creatively it's not a project you should
take even if they are throwing lots of
money at you because you probably won't
do a good job telling that story it may
not be something that's equipped to your
life experiences and so I think that as
a filmmaker and anytime a filmmaker is
evaluating what film they should make
they of course should think about the
business side what is the potential for
this film but also is this film
something creatively that I'm equipped
to tell and if you can't answer yes to
both of those questions you probably
shouldn't do it
have there been things that you've
turned down absolutely oh yes I've
turned down numerous projects I
yes I've turned down numerous projects I
will sometimes read a screenplay and
it's a complete disaster and I look at
that and I say okay is that we're fixing
this story is the story fixable and if
the answer is no I'm not going to waste
my time with it and sometimes that has
to do with the personality of the person
on the other side just as much as it
does to the content that they presented
me with if I don't think that the person
on the other side of the phone or the
email or the table I'm sitting at is
going to be willing to collaborate and
talk and evolve I'm not going to have a
further conversation about work
that project with them because I know
it's going to be how long are for me and
I like to have pleasant filming
experiences what are some of the
tell-tale signs is it is it a resistance
is it it may be a defensive nosov no
that's fine I don't know why you saw it
that way and and there's no flow kind of
back and forth there's incredible
capacity for people not to see flaws in
their own work and I'm sure all of us
put on blinders you know I can tell you
things about all of my work that I wish
that I had done better in certain scenes
or in different moments I would not be
honest if i sat her and told you that I
thought everything I've ever made was
perfect because I certainly don't but I
think that when you're sitting with
someone are talking with someone that
does that is an indicator that you don't
want to work with them because they
don't have the capacity to grow or
evolve or change you might be Aaron
Sorkin and a brilliant brilliant writer
but even Aaron Sorkin can collaborate
with people and I think if Aaron Sorkin
can do it so can you
you